hey what's up ladies and gentlemen
before we get started I want to remind
everybody about the new giveaway that
I'm doing I haven't mentioned this in
the last four or five videos that I made
so I figured I better let everybody know
in case some people didn't catch it the
first time and there are only about ten
days left until the winners are
announced but at the end of this month
I'm going to be giving away two
different prizes on the same day I have
the world of Ice and Fire book and I
also have this game of Thrones trivia
game the first name that is randomly
selected we'll get to pick which one of
these prizes they want then the second
name that is randomly selected will get
the other prize just go down into the
description of this video and click on
that link which will provide multiple
ways for you to enter and I want to
thank everybody who has participated in
the giveaway so far now let's get
started today I want to talk about a few
characters that I believe are going to
be killed and eventually turned into
white for the main Kings army and as Jon
Snow stated in the most recent teaser
the Great War is upon us and in that war
there is going to be a significant
amount of casualties unfortunately not
only will some of the characters we love
die but they are going to be turned into
whites for at least a short period of
time and I think by the end of season 7
the night king will make it to the wall
and more than likely knock the wall down
one way or another and once that happens
the war will have officially begun
everything in his past will be
completely decimated including the
Nights Watch but before that happens I
think we could see some characters turn
to whites before the end of season 7
ever since Hodor died the discussion
about characters turning into whites
really started to ramp up but the
biggest question everyone was asking was
will we see Hodor again as a wight since
the last time we saw him holding the
door he was basically being ripped apart
by several whites technically since we
didn't see Hodor die on screen that
leaves the door open for a character
like him to return but considering the
circumstances Hodor was in I think it's
a safe bet to say that he's dead but did
he turn into a white and will we see him
again as a white personally I don't
think we will ever see her door again
unfortunately and I know many people was
really uncomfortable with
thought of seeing Hodor again as a white
but I think it would have been really
cool to see that even though we would
have had to see him be killed again but
I would have really enjoyed that extra
layer added to the show I would have
loved to see the look on people's faces
if they did see Hodor again especially
if it would have been brand it would be
really interesting to see a character be
put in that position knowing this is a
person that they once loved but they are
now a white and no longer has free will
over their actions they would have to
decide am I going to kill this person
because of what they became or will I
try to subdue them and possibly lock
them up and hope that after the night
king is killed this person will be
turned back into a normal human being
even if they are still dead I'm very
anxious to see everyone's reaction when
the time eventually comes for them to
come face to face with someone they know
and love who is now a white and trying
to kill them I know what I would do but
it would definitely be a tough decision
the only example of a character we know
and root for that's a white right now is
Benjen stark but only brain and Meera
know that he's even alive and luckily
for them benjin wasn't fully turned into
a white and trying to kill them unless
Benjen Starks blood allows him to keep
his free will and own decision-making
now that would be very interesting
considering the night king himself may
have stark blood but just going off the
way benjin looks he appears to be a
fully turned white even though he said
he was saved by the children of the
forest we really still don't know
benjin's true intentions as of right now
I'd like to believe that he's still
fighting for the south
but until things play out we're just
going to have to speculate about that
but we did see characters we know at
hardhome get turned into white but
personally I wasn't emotionally invested
into any of those characters at all so
it didn't affect me in any way to see
those Wellings be turned into whites
even though it did make the knight
king's army that much larger but now
let's get into the heart of this
discussion that I really want to talk
about which is who I believe we will see
get killed by the knight king in his
army in turning a more meat for the
knight king's army most of us i watch
all my videos are well aware of the plot
leaked by now and in that plot leaked it
says that Jon Snow is going to go north
of
to capture a white in order to get that
white self to show to all the other
lords that the threat beyond the wall is
real
Jon Snow is going to be accompanied by
tormund Gendry the Hound Jorah Mormont
Thor's of mirror and beric Dondarrion it
says that in the process of capturing
this white they're going to come under
attack by the mighty in his army and it
also says that Thoris of mirror is going
to be killed by a zombie polar bear but
I got to be honest with you I do not
think we're going to see a polar bear
turned into a white as much as I want to
see that I just don't think it's true
but I do hope I'm wrong because that
would be an incredible looking thing to
see and terrifying thing to see at the
same time however I do believe the words
of Muir will die during this mission and
not only do I think force of Muir will
die on this mission but I also think
beric Dondarrion will die as well
Thoros and Barrack are going to become
whites even if only for a short period
of time they will be killed by the night
king in his army I think forest and
barracks sole purpose in this plot is to
get the Hound to Jon Snow now I know in
the show they said they're on a mission
for the Lord of Light but for television
and plot purposes I think once they are
able to get the helm teamed up with Jon
Snow their characters will become
expendable I think that's why they
brought the Hound back in the first
place to get him with Jon Snow and
fighting for the north and to get him
back into Arya and Saunders storyline
but once that is accomplished Thoris and
barrack will no longer be needed they're
not going to resurrect Jon again I know
one part of the leak said that Barrack
would give John the kiss of life and
bring him back but come on having John
Snow died again and brought back again
would be ridiculous and really devalue
his character if we know he's going to
be saved every single time that he dies
but I think forest and Barrack are the
two most expendable characters right now
that is going to go on this mission with
Jon north of the wall they definitely
aren't going to kill Jorah
tormund Gendry or the Hound during this
mission they have much bigger roles to
play but someone is going to die during
this mission in order to add that extra
layer of drama and those are the two
characters I see that they could
possibly take out
and of course we're going to also see
Uncle Benjen get fully turned into a
white I made a video about this a few
months ago Benjen will end up fighting
for the knight King and I think Jon Snow
will be left with no choice but to kill
his own uncle now that's more than
likely going to happen in season 8 but I
think by the end of season 7 benjin will
be working for the knight King I think
it's just a matter of time he's all
alone up north north of the wall
surrounded by the knight King and his an
entire army I wouldn't be surprised if
he is already a full white but like I
said earlier maybe since he has stark
blood he can still make his own
decisions
maybe he purposely took brand to the
wall that way he can remove its magic
who knows but this video isn't the time
of the place to get into that I also
think the entire Nights Watch will be
killed at Castle black and all of them
are going to be turned into White's
including the Lord Commander and I hate
to say that but it's going to happen the
watch does not stand a chance they have
less than 100 men and they are the first
line of defense against an attack
against the wall once the knight King
makes it through the wall
the watch will be completely destroyed
and I wouldn't be surprised if Castle
black and most of its Nights Watch
members get buried and crushed by the
wall when it comes down those large
pieces of ice that make up the wall
weigh tons and if the wall comes
crumbling down then that base won't
stand a chance against ice of that
weight falling from that height in the
end I don't think there's going to be a
purpose for the Nights Watch anyway and
if you want to hear more about that I
did make a video specifically about the
future of the Nights Watch in which I
explain everything that I think happens
at Castle black and what will become of
the watch after the war for the dawn is
over but since I don't think the wall is
going to fall until the end of season 7
there won't be too many characters that
come into contact with the night king in
his army but since Jon will be taking
men north of the wall that gives them an
opportunity for characters to die and be
turned into whites during season 8 when
the north is wide open in the night King
and his men come marching down and
sweeping through towns and villages
we're going to see many many characters
we know and love be killed and turn into
whites but I'll save my season 8
predictions about who will become
White's then for another video since
I've rambled
on this one but I want to thank you guys
for spending the time with me today to
hear my thoughts about this topic
comment below and tell me which
characters you believe are going to be
turned into whites
I think it's obvious that Uncle Benjen
is eventually going to become a full
white but I think Thoreau said barek are
going to be turned into whites as well
and I think Hodor will probably never
see again but comment below and let me
know what you think about this let me
know if you think the entire 9th walk is
going to be turned into whites as well
like I do eventually it's going to
happen let's just hope it's not what
characters we love the most but I'm
curious to see what you think about this
anyway that's my time for today thanks
again and I'll see you in the next one
bye